hello and welcome to the lobby game
spots weekly hangout every tuesday at 2
p.m pacific right here on
gamespot.com i'm your host daniel dwyer
and i'm joined by mr andrew brown and
eric tay which must mean one thing we're
talking about overwatch oh
that's that's the we should see the
title phrase that happens when you boot
the game right on the beta no no just
make that up it's just how we say it
ever since that one trip
over yeah it's almost been 12 months
since we drove our asses down to anaheim
to play overwatch for the first time
when they announced it at blizzcon 2014
uh today the beta opens up a closed beta
super closed it seems invite only by the
looks of things that's how we've that's
what you've got that's how we got it my
account still hasn't unlocked so if you
work at blizzard please please please
please please and it kind of sucks that
we get to talk about it and no one can
like join us complete your matches yeah
unless you're lucky enough to be one of
the people that got in somehow if you're
a youtuber like you're probably killing
us right now but that's cool but yeah so
tay hasn't played it in a year we played
it just a few weeks ago yes we did it
may have shifted in in a little bit of
form but it's basically the same game uh
there's 18 heroes i think right now in
beta and it's like four or five
different maps switch anytime it's not
like you're locked in for the whole
match as many people can be as many
heroes at the same time you could have
like a team of all tracers which i've
always wanted to do and get gamepl
varying abilities in these characters
like super different um on each one
there's but the but they're divided up
into like tank which has lots of health
support which either makes you run
faster or
uh heals uh
defensive which
kind of covers a lot which is builders
and turret and
snipers which is awesome and then
there's offensive which are like just
people that shoot stuff basically and
tracer who's awesome who's like the
poster girl is that your favorite so far
do you think world heroes yeah no i i've
never actually played tracy oh really
yeah
um is bastion still op no well i just
suck it
i'm the wrong person to ask that because
apparently i can't get kills anymore in
overwatch like it's recently where yeah
it's been about morning what about you
guys like yeah
eric what's up what's it been like for
you coming back after like a year of not
playing it uh it's still a lot of fun i
i want to give credit where credit's due
it's it granted it is a beta but the ui
has gone a lot better from what it was
before there's a lot of like good uh you
know just helpful beginner tips you know
everything that you need to know about
your hero you can easily access with f1
i mean yes the game is pretty much like
four buttons but every like hero or
however whatever you want to call them
uh you know does
things differently they have different
movement mechanics and different like
you know left click right click um but
yeah it's it's still a lot of fun uh i
like andy it took it's taken a little
bit to get back into it i'm still having
loads of fun it's just that i'm not
dominating like we were that one time i
guess
so i think it's just getting used to
that and i i think also for me
personally i haven't played a keyboard
mouse shooter
in so long after you're on that
destination i'm on that destiny i played
halo destiny rust so i'm on that those
thumb sticks shut off opposable thumbs
instead of you know the precision of a
mouse which is what i used to like
clamor about so right now it's closed uh
it seems like this might be going on
indefinitely yeah this would have been
said but by the looks of it and what
they did with heroes perhaps this will
just be it until the game's out they've
also said that they're going to have
open weekends for that's right stress
testing yeah they haven't said when
exactly it's going to be but if you're
interested in playing overwatch um make
sure that you opt into the beta stuff on
battlenet because yeah they're going to
be opening this up for everyone else um
a couple of like cool things though too
that speaking to like blizzard doing
betas basically they can change like any
of this of course like yeah
that's what they want to do
yeah but one of the big things that
they've kind of done is they got rid of
a leaderboard when you
press tab or whatever get the score
screen so and they've also made a
distinction between eliminations and
finishers so talk about that i'm not
quite because sure
because the interesting thing about that
that's you know usually when you hit tab
on a on a fps fps it says it ranks them
based on like kills whatever points and
and i thought that that seemed like a
kind of a piecemeal change but it
actually does kind of change
yeah like the fee it pushes people
towards a team play that i feel like a
lot of other games even like cs and
stuff yeah you're all about the kill you
do right you just want to be on top of
the leaderboard and in this
a lot of the heroes actually don't
finish other heroes like they don't get
that blow um the killing blow but they
do a lot of damage or they do a lot of
support or they get you there in the
battle faster or they soak up damage
yeah which is like a huge part of the
game it's just soaking up damage i think
that's that's another like fun element
that makes this game
like that like more appealing because
you can play differently right like you
play mercy and you can play support the
whole time you can heal or you can give
buff damage and you don't even have to
do any damage if you don't want to but
her secondary like her pistol is
actually pretty good from the last time
i played it and so you know you have
varying styles of play you know like you
want to try to
make a team that's kind of
cohesive and like kind of well-rounded
and even the even the tutorial or the ui
will tell you hey by the way you don't
have that many offensive players on your
team so maybe one of you guys should
switch kind of things right like you
don't have to yeah but it's like oh you
don't have any tanks at the moment yeah
or you've got too many healers or
something like that too many support
people yeah which is terrible actually
yeah
it's a absolute [ __ ] nightmare and
you can switch like i said before like
the cool thing is we played a match and
it's like all right we need to kind of
step up a little bit more something and
i'm like i need more damage i need more
tanky stuff so i'm like i'll switch to
the ape guy winston winston and just get
in there and mess up but not because you
haven't been playing good with somebody
else necessarily necessarily but perhaps
because yeah exactly like maybe this the
the
tactics have changed i was playing as um
uh
i forget one of the snipers who like
launches oh no she's support but she
also like throws mines up she makes the
twitter maker oh no no that's uh
whatever her name oh yeah yeah she's got
a crazy name
but i was playing as her and then after
a while um it didn't make any sense for
me to be making the teleporter because
we've been pushed back so far so i was
like i'll swap to somebody else so it is
a lot of like on the fly sort of team
tactics which i guess really does push
this into the esports sort of area which
is that is very much what blizzard are
trying to do what do you think about
that eric i think that when you if it
does if and when it does get to that
point i think that
the game is going to be accessible for
everyone but when it hits that kind of
esports level they're going to probably
have draft modes um right which would be
kind of weird because like that's not
how this game maybe is meant to play
casually but like in in terms of esports
there's probably going to be picks and
bands i wouldn't be surprised you know
like to see
like
certain players playing specific roles
almost moba s right because again you
have tank offensive support so like i i
wouldn't be shocked to see kind of
locked in modes for one map and the maps
are pretty fast like they're five to ten
minutes sometimes you get to extend it
over time and stuff like that but it's
interesting though that was brought up
when we were a blizzard and they sort of
replied saying that they haven't ruled
out doing any of that stuff but
especially at this stage with the beta i
think they're keeping all options open
they're keeping the gameplay as open as
possible and then they sort of alluded
to the fact that perhaps later they
might start to trim down some of the
choice within different game modes but
right now they very much seem to be kind
of let's throw out all these characters
all these game modes and then you know
figure out what people are like warming
to or not and i guess the one of the
things i want to ask you guys about is
that the game mode specifically seems to
be the one area in which it's rather
traditional like they have a
the sort of the what is that loadout
mode which is in team fortress or
payload
team fortress 2 and the rest of the
stuff is pretty much normal
yeah sort of different variants on that
um
is that something that sort of concerns
you guys or not or is there enough
variety with andy within the characters
the heroes themselves to keep you happy
i've never thought of it that way
because man like
right it's been such like a i just want
to play more i just want to play more
and every chance we get it's like who
cares what the math is like yeah so i
don't know it'll be weird to see
if it gets old or something or like you
start to see through the cracks a little
bit yeah if you're like oh the payload
it's easy to defend this because you
just set up like two turrets two like
bastions and then everybody else is a
tank like a wine harsh at the front yeah
yeah so like it's it'll be cool to see
that stuff like
crowdsourced or whatever
i mean it'll be a min maxing of like
once people figure out maps there's like
so many spots that people
haven't even figured out or you start
dying and you're like oh where the heck
is that person you're like oh they're
all the way up there because they
figured out that they could go there so
do you remember the map where we went
before where there was a choke point and
we basically put up two turrets we put
up the sentinel or bastion and we put up
the other guy uh the the little rush the
little norway stormborn
yeah yeah
they said in that one so we we in this
map basically got everyone down that
chokepoint just blazed them they never
had a chance right uh apparently in that
map there was a place you could fly over
the top when we played at a blizzard
there was an entire new route to the
left where they could flank so they've
already changed lots of the map stuff so
i wonder you know you're right they'll
probably keep updating this for the next
couple of weeks and months that was for
sure something i noticed after not
playing for a year it's like yeah it
seems like when you start there's kind
of like either two or three
ways you're gonna exit your starting
point to wherever you need to go there's
like the main entrance door and then
there's like two little side doors and
that was like a team fortress problem as
well around the start in team fortress 2
is that a lot of the places when you got
right at the gates if they decided to
like dump on you right yeah you they
could actually pin you in there oh yeah
you could have to work your way out of
there and that happened like sometimes
at the first press thing yeah i was
pinning people against the wall as soon
as they walk out as reinhardt just like
doing the slam and it was really pissing
people off and and that
i don't know if anybody is going to jump
in this game on the open weekends
they're probably going to get worked and
then they're going to yeah because that
can happen like josh our other guy here
he was like all right overwatch i got it
and after he like didn't like have a
good match yeah he's like i'm not gonna
play this again they have one character
in there because that was the thing i
think that sort of shocked all of their
shocked all of us surprised us was how
different each character is it doesn't
feel like classes within the same thing
they do very much feel like they have
unique abilities because they do but i
love how there's one character in there
which is basically a call of duty
soldier and just quake
so everyone's like unique movement
ability on shift and his one is just
wrong yeah it's like the only one that's
actually pretty fun i played him just
now he's he's pretty standard like
here's your standard fps guys he's
called like soldier four
seventy-six seventy-six yeah
but he's he's the guy that like if
you're starting i think if i think even
the tutorial makes you use him i think
um so i'm not shocking like here's your
set guy that you can kind of start with
that you
tried and true you you know how to play
him you know what i mean and then you'll
start dibbling and dabbling here and
there um but yeah i mean like like you
said it could be hard to get into if you
get rolled a couple times in the
beginning but i mean me rob and mike at
like side side track here like we were
playing halo warzone and then we got
rolled and he was like oh that sucks you
know what i mean like that's gonna
happen with i think fps shooters and i
think
you just have to have a little bit of
patience and and then find your hero i
think once you find one of your heroes
you're like start kicking well you're
like all right i'm going to use this guy
for a while and then
we maybe move off for a little while i'm
trying to see do i need to go back but
always have that safety net yeah
a lot of opportunities for people to
become
player coaches on youtube like oh yeah
or like do those videos like here's how
to play yo man you want to be sick
reinhardt this is what you got to do
because it's pretty involved dude like
yeah there's people at blizzard talking
to you the whole time when you're
playing at the events they're like all
right so do this all right jump out and
they're like combinations
yeah and they're like all right now try
to like blend you should do this yeah
you're like oh my gosh it totally
changes the whole thing like we'd
reinhardt and then i was that was that
the brazilian dude who's got the lucy
yeah the beatbox yeah and if i doubled
him up with reinhardt certainly
reinhardt was this like super fast tank
so yeah anyway we're getting pretty deep
into this for a game that's still in
closed beta um thanks very much guys for
coming on talking about overwatch i
enjoy watching you play while i wait for
my bottlenet account to unlock for the
rest of the week we need you man if you
are interested at all in overwatch make
sure you sign up uh on your baldnet
account opt-in to the beta stuff there
so you can get in on those open weekends
uh but in the meantime if or if you
don't get in at all let us know what you
think of our watch have you watched any
of our coverage on gamingspot.com over
the past couple of weeks and months uh
we're definitely big fans of it and we'd
like to know what you guys think of it
as well stick your thoughts in the
comment box below all right we got a
bunch more chat today uh it's a
first-person shooter day today basically
we're gonna talk about uh halo five
mahari's done the review and he's gonna
be back in well he's almost on the
review and we're gonna get him in to
talk about um what
score he might be giving us is this
no not four not four is he giving a four
i don't know maybe he's given a four is
he giving a four i don't know you're
you're making all these finger gestures
with your hands finger gestures like
it'll be like this it could be like this
it could be like that
like be like
i can't even tell you can't even tell
what's on the other hand who knows
is it that
is it that is it another 10 or 10 who
knows uh we're probably not going to
tell you but maybe we will stay tuned
i'll be back in a second first of all
here's that sick drive club bikes
trailer you all been wanting to watch
drive club bikes is a whole new
experience to drive club introducing
staggeringly fast and agile super bikes
racing in the drive of the universe on
beautiful tracks at day and night all in
the connected and social world of drive
club where i grew up we used to see them
on a man tt every year so
big challenge for me was to really get
that sense of excitement and noise in
drive club bikes
multiplayer and drive for bikes is
awesome lots of opportunity to overtake
lots of opportunity to show off pull
wheels as you pass each other over the
finish line riding with your clubs it
feels amazing obviously it's fast paced
it's close action it's wheel to wheel
it's incredibly exciting and powerful
riding on these amazing super bikes
you've got a whole new bikes tour
you've got new challenges
uh new face offs a whole new mode skill
mode where you get to show off wheelies
stoppies and you know play around the
bike a lot more than you would do with a
car which is great fun you know when
you're on a bike it's all about hip
placements you know shifting weight back
and forth for when you're doing wheelies
or stoppies all those sort of things
really need us to build the characters
from ground ups and
put them all in new fancy leathers you
can customize the leather so they match
your team colours and of course the same
for the helmets the clubs in drive club
now include bikes and cars and then
everything that you do when you're
racing in drive club now on bikes on a
car whichever it is that you want to
race with you'll be earning more fame
for your club so you've been locking new
rewards together new events together and
you'll be able to get more out playing
drive club with each other drive club is
a constantly evolving game and drive
club bikes is that next step adding
staggeringly detailed bikes from the
world's best manufacturers and it's a
completely new way to play drive club we
spend a lot of time uh analyzing the
bikes whether it's for audio so there's
microphones placed all over the bikes
and then they're put on racetracks and
taken up to the absolute top speeds and
we record every single sound pop noise
that they make and then yeah we do
exactly the same we scan down to the
nearest millimeter
we get all the cab data that the
manufacturers give us so it you know
everything's as close as possible to
physically being correct
it's that sense of flow through the
tracks and then chasing down opposition
it's something that you don't quite get
with them
drive club in the cars because cars big
meaty things and they're almost muscling
their way around the tracks where
there's a lightness of touch the bikes
as they go through and then when that
transfers to multiplayer you get big
packs weaving in and out of each other
and it gives a really good multiplayer
experience so yeah it's that sense of
flow that's really different from cars
for the players
one of the biggest games of the year is
out today certainly a massive game if
you're an xbox one owner and one of the
big exclusives coming out this year halo
5 guardians out finally today uh by the
sounds of mike a lot of people are
playing online right now yeah there were
a bunch of people i was playing
throughout the day we had pre-release
playlists yeah and it took a little bit
to get into war zone and arena matches
but today it was i don't think i waited
longer than 10 seconds to get in cool
your review is going live at three
o'clock in about 30 minutes yeah we're
gonna give away the score here though
live but before we do that uh talk to me
a little bit about the idea of the
provisional review obviously there was a
provisional review up on gamespot on
sunday without a score without final
thoughts and what was the idea behind
that yeah so a lot of times uh with
multiplayer shooters or just any kind of
multiplayer game that's going to be
based around a lot of servers
we just we didn't want to do a
disservice to readers by publishing a
score and everything and having opinions
on it because i could have had the best
time ever in multiplayer but yeah if it
doesn't work for a week or two after
launch then
what's the point you can't get in so we
wanted to make sure i provided some
thoughts and everything in the but we
want to keep it brief my review
the actual review was much more in-depth
of course um so we just wanted to make
sure the servers were up because the
embargo was a day before release right
so
not the entire public so like australia
like and new zealand had the game before
us and europe and everything so we want
to make sure once the servers are at
their peak that's working like it's all
working especially i remember this time
last year having conversations with
chris waters who ended up belaying the
master chief collection review i think
we didn't score that game for two weeks
until it came out yep uh all right put
us out of our misery hello five
guardians mike mccarty what did you give
it give it an eight out of ten eight out
of ten yep all right we talked to you
about it last week with the campaign
stuff a little bit yeah obviously you're
a massive halo fan and you've been
you've played every single game um what
is it you like about the multiplayer uh
what what what is it that sort of you
because i know the campaign stuff will
get you in a little bit you weren't
super super hot on sure but the
multiplayer stuff what is it about that
really sold it to you sure so i in my
opinion this is the best halo
multiplayer has ever been um you know
like halo 2 sparked xbox live i don't
think it'd be where it is now if it
weren't for halo 2. and i played you
know cat and mouse cat and mouse on
blood gulch back in the day in halo 2
all the time
swat when they first started bringing it
out um played a lot of halo 3
multiplayer four i was actually like i
think i share the sentiment of a lot of
people four which is my least favorite i
think 343
had a good effort with multiplayer i
liked their campaign for for the most
part um but you know they introduce the
call of duty kind of progression when
you get experience then build your
loadouts
where there is a new progression in halo
5 but in arena like the classic just
team slayer capture the flag swat
playlists it's classic halo the power
weapons are scattered throughout the map
uh you're starting with assault rifle
pistol uh in most modes and you know
everybody's starting on an equal playing
field i kind of prefer that well at
least like it's weird that that's fresh
considering that's kind of the way halo
always was but yeah it's it is fresh
because everyone else goes too or
something yeah just a classic shooter
kind of feel and control yeah and yeah
they'll tell you their spawn timers for
the you know the power weapons the
rocket launcher the sniper rifle the
plasma caster which is new and i really
like that because both teams will see
like this 11 10 nights so you're you're
like all right we're going for that but
[ __ ] so are they it's interesting but
like even old arena shooters that are
coming back unreal tournament does the
exact same thing it actually shows you
how much is left oh yeah it creates
these awesome clash points where
everybody's just fighting over the
rocket launcher and then of course
someone gets it and blows up half their
team on accident which has happened to
me um but yeah the multi it feels
awesome
because arena is arena's great but one
of my favorite parts about halo 5 and
just something i think is really fresh
for the shooter genre in general is war
zone the new mode and it's it's very
moba inspired and i'm not a big moba
player but i see their merit and i
understand why people follow them so
closely um there's just this great blend
of pve and pvp combat so this is this
replaces big team battle players which a
lot of people were kind of pissed about
at first but i once i played warzone it
erased any doubts i had really um so you
you do have a progression system but you
will start off there are three capture
points um and then both teams have a
core so kind of the fortress and mobas
okay you can take these capture points
and those let you spawn across the map
in more places you get these uh wreck
consoles to call in power weapons
vehicles um but you can also shoot ai
like right here there's prometheans
guarding this oh so it's like um in
titanfall or something it's like the the
minions are like creeps like
yeah and you get the you kill those and
they contribute you can see at the
bottom here there's a energy meter
that's your currency pretty much
throughout the match it builds up to i
think a maximum of nine which i've never
hit how many humans are on either a team
um it is a minimum of nine versus nine
but it can be up to twelve versus twelve
okay excellent um and there's there's
raid which is just you know capturing
there's a salt which is just capturing
the three neutral zones and then
destroying the core but the
classic war zone raid is my favorite
because you there's it's not just
killing other human or ai and taking
capture points every once in a while a
boss will spawn oh wow with a weather an
ai boss whether it's a regular boss
which is worth 25 points or a legendary
boss which obviously as the name implies
they take more to kill but they're worth
150 points and both teams are just
pretty much racing to a thousand points
okay so and those these bosses aren't
affiliated with one or the other teams
they're neutral okay um so that's also
kind of like the power weapons we're
just talking about there'll be a
legendary boss and it's just like a moba
where the team that gets the last hit to
drain the hellfire gets kidding me so
today
yes so taking over my desk today and
we're watching and there's a legendary
boss and i had a rail gun which is a
really powerful weapon and i was there i
was just crouching so they couldn't see
me on the motion sensor he's just
waiting i was waiting three guys were
shooting at him and all of a sudden i
was like oh and i killed him with a rail
gun and i know that they're all pissed
and swearing and everything they killed
me right after but i got 150 points they
got one from
excellent and so that's the the great
thing about warzone like i was i was up
i was down today like
700 points to 300 and you know in most
cases that's you're screwed yeah but
then we got a legendary kill we captured
a few more points to start getting more
spawns we we all started spawning
scorpion tanks and we started we still
lost but only by like 60 points oh wow
which is 60 kills or
two legendary kills one of the sort of i
guess linchpins of the halo franchise
has always been the fact that this was a
first person shooter which really
integrated vehicles into its combat
incredibly well like even the you know
the first first game you know there are
some levels that we still remember today
um
what's it like in war zone with the
weapon with the vehicles do they feel
like they're just power-ups in it or do
they feel like they're like as tactical
aspect to the gameplay as well very much
tactical aspect um you can once you can
either spend your the energy at the
bottom those five green this looks like
whoever
power-ups like gameplay or like
camouflage but you can also get
vehicles and then that's where it comes
in because you can get a
scorpion that will help you take out a
legendary boss but then someone other
team could just easily call in a rocket
launcher if they have rocket launcher
cards to burn through and take you out
so it's very balanced like despite the
fact that you can call in a scorpion
tank there's always just these like
checks and balances in the requisition
system which is a whole that's the
progression system which you could talk
about that for a while too but
it's it's very balanced but at the same
time
vehicles yeah can turn the tide of a
battle
just
just as easily as you know killing a
legendary box excellent uh we'll talk
about the campaign in a second but first
of all another aspect that we didn't
really get to talk about much last week
was co-op um how does that work how many
people can play and what's it like so
you could play up to four people um you
know people got kind of upset when
they heard you can't play split screen
co-op yeah which i agree with i love
that um but
playing four-player co-op in the
campaign it runs very smoothly and i
think you know they focused a lot on
making the online experience smooth and
the result is really smooth um you get
the campaign is pretty much structured
like people who played halo 2 will feel
a little familiar with it you bounce
between one day you bounce between the
master chief and the arbiter the elite
of course um this is sort of the same
thing except you're bouncing between
team osiris which is a bunch of spartan
fours led by uh agent jameson locke who
was introduced in um nightfall like
it's canonical but it's not in the games
um then you have blue team which is
master chief and three of his spartan
twos who were in like you know the books
that i used to read but you each
and each of the spartans has their own
separate loadouts uh so you know fred
will start with a dmr and a pistol chief
will start with assault rifle and pistol
like the classic one um you know lock
has a battle rifle
but
you they all have like certain character
traits that kind of
contribute to how they they don't really
play differently but um you know like
kelly can run a little faster fred can
take a little more damage chiefs shields
recharge a little faster this is rob
about to punt this grunt for the
um halo veterans will remember the grunt
birthday party skull uh when you when
you turn it on it's just anytime you get
a grunt shot they pop into confetti and
there's oh yeah of course yeah and
that's how you get it you punt that
grunt off the side
so yeah so this is uh jake rob eric and
i playing fort player and is it is it
more fun do you think playing co-op than
it is oh absolutely um for a few reasons
because there are a lot of branching the
new level design of the campaign which
gameplay-wise the campaign is awesome i
love it um you can
you can kind of see these wide open
areas they're more like these arenas or
sandboxes than these linear pathways
yeah which i was kind of apprehensive
about because i liked the linearity of
halo it felt like they were funneling me
through certain areas and kind of
designing it to be a certain way but you
can replay these a second time and it'll
be very different because you'll crash
through this wall and you'll find uh
like ghosts or vehicles that you didn't
know about before or um there's a
there's a mission early on like the
third mission or something when rob
played it and he didn't know that you
could turn on these auto turrets that
help you like six of these huge gatling
turrets and i like stumbled on it yeah
and then i played it completely
differently and i let those do the work
um but co-op you can kind of split up
and say you take the fuel rod cannon you
take the scorpion i'm gonna get in this
phaeton cover you guys from the air it's
really fun and uh it also
negates the ai which
ranges from remarkably good to
abysmal
which is you know it's it's kind of
always been the handle
right yeah i mentioned that in my review
that it's inconsistent ai yeah um so if
you get down this is the first halo in
the campaign where you can you just get
down and can get revived and uh if
you're playing single player or two
player or three three is always
interesting because you have that one ai
who everybody's just really worried
about yeah um or if you're playing with
eric tay everybody's worried about him
no i'm just kidding tay's gonna halo um
you'll be playing and then you'll say
hey come get me and then instead of two
like in co-op you can say you two keep
shooting cover us i'll go get him yeah
for sure and then
an ai you know they'll be like she runs
up to you gets killed then you'll call
for help again it's a train of like
it's not all gears of war one problem
yeah or you know maybe you know
pre-half-life co-op software yeah it
kind of doesn't make it as fun and
experience yeah um so yeah much more fun
played co-op then absolutely sounds like
it's very fun to play cards it sounds
like you're talking about a game that is
you know to not use the old reviewers
outage fans of the series will
definitely get behind halo 5. but what
was it about the the game even as a fan
of the series yourself that stopped it
from crawling up towards the wonderful
reaches of nines and tens sure so
uh aside from the ai which i which i
mentioned as a negative my review
because it can get pretty cloying at
times um
the the story which halo 4 for as boring
as i thought the campaign was the
gameplay the story i actually really
liked they focused more on
characterization with the chief and
cortana because cortana is like his only
friend
really like besides three spartans but
these three are like you know teammates
more than friends colleagues yeah
counters and social friends partners and
pics yeah um but partners in combat
evolved
exactly uh pisces pisces and
five reversed that and i
love the campaign and the game plan it
feels so great especially the new
spartan maneuvers which we could talk
about if you want but
the story is
bad the plot is very disjointed and
broken uh there are a bunch of cut
scenes between missions that
they fade to black before i actually
three times through the campaign the
first time i played it like three times
i remember counting i thought i
accidentally skipped a cut scene over by
like moving the controller pressing
start or something which was
disappointing because
i love the story of halo i read all the
i'm a halo geek i read all right
yeah halo fall of reach is like one of
my favorite uh sci-fi books and
but these cutscenes just end they'll
devote and they waste their time with
them too um or they'll they'll devote 30
seconds to this ai just ranting about
something really inconsequential instead
of telling you why you're going to this
planet that you're on
so the missions lose a lot of impact
because i don't know what's going on
which you know like it sounds
negligible but
if they tell a good story surrounding
the missions they can make like add a
lot of momentum and impact to these
missions that you're playing which is
something that's happened in like at
least the first three halo games which
felt like you know it's you're right
people will say that that's sort of like
a flippant aspect to it but the parts in
the old halo games that had bad parts
stories people still remember as being
irritating so for that to be continuous
throughout the campaign yeah obviously
it wears whereas only a bit yeah and i i
remember i still remember when they
first introduced the flood in halo 1.
there's the moment where you go into
that room and you see all these dead
marines but then you watch the recording
of that same room you're in from like a
few hours before yeah and you see the
flood attack and then you cut back to
the real time you're like holy [ __ ]
that's this room that's an awesome way
to tell a story because
you're still in the story but they're
not it's not you know it's showing and
not telling in this game they try
they try
yeah and they
they just don't the cutscenes don't
provide any context context for what
you're doing and also any story that's
told in the game
there's a lot of audio logs you can pick
up which i appreciate that it adds to
the backstory but
it's such a the gameplay of the campaign
is so you know momentous and it keeps
pushing you forward but those slow it
down and also you have to stand near
them the first time you get them to
actually hear them all right and you can
go back and like review them in the main
menu but you have to stand next to them
and you just wait around to listen to
them and then also there'll be a lot of
actual main like the main narrative like
the audio logs from
uh the ward in this character that comes
into it uh just other teammates will
play over that so you can't really hear
not only what you just found but also
what is being told you that just should
be essential to the plot right and then
they're also a few of these missions
that are combat free and i say they're
missions because if you go to the menu
it says there's 15 i think but really
there's 12 missions because these other
three are these kind of like rpg-ish
towns oh cool okay yeah which at first i
was very confused i was it was the first
time i've ever played a halo mission
without
shooting anything yeah which makes me
sound like originally it was an rpg it
was a well it was a strategy game
right and you go around these towns
talking these people and they their
dialogue is well written but
it slowed it down i just don't think it
fits in this game at all and they're
they really
three times
yeah one one is the same area just
coming back through it to talk to
catherine halsey and there is backstory
i think it just could have been told in
cutscenes but these cutscenes are tough
to make they look awesome i'm sure
that's no small deal to make them but so
some irk some yeah the the campaign the
story stuff wasn't super fun the co-op
having uh i guess some some rough around
the edges ai um and then of course the
the these weird little rpg but apart
from the campaign stuff multiplayer
multiplayer
and the campaign like don't let me deter
you from playing it's fun yeah because
the spartan abilities you can ground
pound you can smash you can you know
people can split up there's one mission
where there's two people in the phaetons
the ships covering the two on the ground
which we have a video of it uh that
video we were showing of rob eric jake
and i that's that mission they're all
really fun do those spartan um moves
transfer over to the multiplayer yeah oh
yeah and they can they're not essential
to being great but if you want to get
good at halo there's people that are
already using them really well actually
i saw rob killing i think two people
wanted a grand stomach oh it's tough to
pull off you have to charge it up but
yeah then you have the running sprint
smash now and then you have the the dash
which is just this quick jet pack like a
modern advanced warfare kind of and uh i
was kind of apprehensive about that too
but like someone should be shooting me
i'll just dart around a corner or get
away from a grenade or even someone with
an energy sword like i'm rattling these
off because there's so many new it opens
up so many new options and i'm not used
to them but the more i play them the
more i'm kind of
super on board with all of them yeah and
the halo games always you know have a
lot of options in terms of gameplay so i
guess last thing to talk about um
campaign multiplayer we've talked about
it all uh forge is coming later this
year december last i heard yeah it's not
at release now um they've been showing a
lot of cool things too uh i've actually
never i've created stuff back when you
used to play um
griff griff ball okay i forgot what it's
called it's it's like it was kind of
like rocking
with gravity hammers instead of driving
cars
i remember when i first played rocket
league i'm like this reminds me of that
um
and i did create maps i never use it too
much but there there's always a wealth
of options there i'm sure once that
comes out there will be more maps in the
arena and arena playlist of people like
sometimes bungie
bungie used to promote them um 343 i'm
sure might do the same thing like really
good user created maps they'll put them
into playlists throughout each week and
feature users which i'm looking forward
to that because there's some very smart
people out there making maps for sure
that little five percent of uh creators
that make everything else for the rest
of us thank god for them yeah thanks so
much mike for coming on telling us all
about halo yeah five guardians uh we're
gonna make you stick around because in
the next segment eric tay is gonna come
on we're gonna have a little pow pow
about which uh
which bungie franchise or x-bungie
franchise is the top multiplayer
first-person console shooter we're
playing right now so stick around if you
want to see that bad boy we'll be back
in just a minute right after we check
out the new trailer for david kaja's new
video game this is put your hands up
mike put your hands up
put your hands up for detroit
we love this trailer
peggy's all right
detroit
this is where it all began
the world's forge
the place where it all started
and it will all end
one error
and i came to life
i stepped out of the darkness and i
opened my eyes
first there was the fear the light the
noise the cold
and the fear again
i could feel my hands shaking my heart
pounding in my chest
life running into my veins
i wanted to live
i fought for that
i had to find out what was outside
i had to see daylight
feel sunshine on my skin
wind on my face
to see the world
the colors
the smells
but the world is not what i imagined
it is dark and cold
it is harsh and violent
unfair and brutal
it almost convinced me i was nothing
less than an object
just
an obedient machine
but deep inside me i could feel
something different
a gentle and warm whisper telling me
that i am
i had to escape i had no choice
escape to love to hope to live
to figure out what that force inside me
was
maybe i will change the world maybe i'll
choose a different path
now
it's up to me to decide
my name is cara
i am one of them
this
is our story
ps4 for the players
halo 5 guardians comes out today destiny
i guess it
finally came out about two weeks ago
15th took a year and yeah yeah sorry i'm
an independent adjudicator um didn't
sound very independent in this
conversation uh hi how you doing we're
here to talk about destiny and halo 5
which is the better first person online
multiplayer
single player experience for your home
video game console i'm joined by eric
tay what's up what's up mike mchardy how
you doing good how are you i'm doing
great i'm looking forward to this one uh
yeah all right both of you played both
yes tay you've played the campaign for
halo 5 you've played more destiny than
i've had hot meals in my entire life um
mike you reviewed taking king and
destiny sorry and uh guardians guardians
uh halo 5 guardians for gamespot.com
yeah um we're here to talk about which
one's better first of all i want to talk
about i guess where this all kind of
starts which for me is with campaign or
at least that's the traditional way
we've had it uh destiny has a sort of a
non-traditional or like online um
experience halo obviously is more
traditional type of campaign uh mike
first of all i'm going to go with you
why do you think halo 5 has a better
campaign than destiny considering in
your review for halo 5. you didn't think
that campaign was all that good
um yeah this is
so i didn't think the story was that
great the campaign itself is well
designed and fun to play and they
introduced this new level design i think
my love for halo just stems from how fun
it is to just play and destiny feels
great but in my opinion and in my
experience
in that it's just destiny is just
constantly shooting
a bunch of different enemies in the head
yeah taken king did a little bit better
by introducing these new enemy types
ahead abilities but still the best way
to kill them was just to shoot them in
the face which halo you can say the same
for that i'm sure but you sure can each
different enemy like has these more
subtle ways that change how you play and
the fire fights all kind of unfold
differently and feel different to me
each time because you have so many
different i mean destiny you have these
like uh the supers that you can use but
halo especially in halo 5 you have the
ground pound you have the smash
and
you're rubbing your neck already man
it's not a good sign no no no no no no
you're shaking your head what do you
think okay let's talk about the ground
and pound and shoulder charge first of
all both uh titan abilities one of the
classes in destiny uh that came out
first obviously and um in terms of story
yeah it took us a little while to get to
where we were but
us destiny
yeah i sure do no um but it took a while
to get there you know i think
uh they learned a lot uh as you said
with taking king
a lot more just continuity in between
missions there's just more storytelling
um you know little cinematic trailers or
trait like not trailers but little
cinematics in between just storytelling
um better just better like back and
forth with the npcs and
i think part of it too is that
destiny is evolving right and it's it's
the raid is kind of the the harder
portion of the the story that's where
you end up at right because that's where
the big bad boss is and that's where all
the kind of bigger mechanics are right
that are outside of just your shooting
things in the head or in the gut but i
mean it's the same in halo like there's
a knight you're shooting him in the
armpit so that his head opens up yeah
i'm shooting a vex in the stomach like
it's kind of the same thing um but i
think with destiny there's a little bit
more to it because you do have your
supers as as a subclass and your
subclasses for each each class and then
on top of that
with the taken enemies this time around
they have different things that they do
captains will throw blind balls at you
you have to avoid it and so there's i
feel like there's more like movement
than in halo where it's like you're just
hiding more in halo i guess all right in
the interest of uh of uh making sure
everyone has the same amount of time i'm
gonna pass it back over to mike to
retort to that anything you have to say
about that yeah so i don't then halo
five if you were were you really just
hiding behind cover and then shooting
could pop out shoot well uh yeah because
when you play campaign by yourself with
three dumb ai if you don't like the
campaign then chances are you're done
for right is destiny a fun solo
experience no i think it's okay at least
it's it scales a little bit better and
like
i think you're less frustrated from the
fact like if you die you know why you
died right and like it's like
halo you kind of just feel like someone
should revive you well no that's but
that's
if you get down in halo that's your
fault it's not it's not your fault when
the ai's too dumb to revive you but it's
every time i got down i was like oh it's
because i ran into the middle of this
room and i like like you're safe yeah
that's your safety net that's not why
you're done yeah it's more of it's just
more of their attempt to keep it going
instead of just checkpoint checkpoint
checkpoint if it's really tough but halo
especially in halo 5 more than any other
halo you have so many options laid out
before you like you can run up this run
up a path do a ground pound from below
sprint at the next grunt spartan smash
him across turn around obviously fire a
few shots of your battle rifle and throw
a grenade which like destiny does have
that movement but i felt i actually
played destiny more of like take cover
and then shoot at these enemies who
would take varying amounts of bullets to
kill which again taken king did improve
on that but i still felt like halo
these subtle nuances they added to the
movement just completely changed how i
looked at maps especially because the
map design was
i think there's more focus on creating a
good level whereas you know destiny's a
lot more open than halo 5. which i don't
they're not going for the same thing but
i think i personally prefer halo 5 style
which is
sort of linear but these arenas where
you can kind of like it's like a
playground almost and kind of get on
this turret or you know getting this
banshee that you just found or just
completely find this new weapon cast you
didn't even know existed whereas you
know you're more attached to your
character than destiny because it's an
rpg and you're you're gaining new
weapons and you're getting new powers
that your character up until certain
i don't know i really appreciate it
let's move away from the campaign stuff
and talk about multiplayer eric i'm
going to let you have first swing on
this one obviously halo more traditional
multiplayer experience different game
modes but you know isolated from the
campaign what is it about destiny you
think that makes it a better multiplayer
experience in halo 5 guardian um i think
on top like i think max in halo's four
right four people
that you can party up with so in destiny
you can do six and co-op
and co-op yeah if you're playing online
like in one of the other modes you can
have like 12 buddies right yeah easily
okay well well i don't think so you're
talking about co-op campaign you're
talking about well i'm talking about
multiplayer though can you have more
than four in your fire team uh in arena
you can only have four but you can have
in a fire team no but you'll be like
with five at least five other people but
in war zone you could have eleven of
your friends you can have eight other
people in addition to your three friends
yeah no but in addition to his friends
so what i'm trying to say is that in
destiny you can party up to six people
which is two people more than um halo so
you can get more buddies in that you
know that you want to play with that
maybe four people's not enough two is
more but it doesn't necessarily mean
better sure that's fine but then i would
like i like to bring in john carlo or
josh to my raid because you can do six
people raids that you can't do in halo
and i think that's one of the big
proponents there and i think that
multiplayer is ever evolving in destiny
and one of the things is that's pretty
cool too is there's a commitment from
bungie to keep patching and making
things better so like when pvp gets out
of hand if a gun is out of hand or if
guns are out of hand they will patch
that and they will fix it and they've
been they've been doing that more and
more and more and on top of that because
of how destiny is set in this world they
can do fun events like the halloween
event just happened yesterday like
nobody saw it coming um and it's just
this cool little thing that everyone
gets to try out like you don't even have
to have a fire team or anything you can
just do it on your own and experience
all these fun little halloween things
with you know masks um and doing all
these little side fun missions that you
can never do in halo so uh what about
what do you think of that mike where's
your goddamn halo 5
halloween mask at well they do do like
special event playlists for multiplayer
okay you can't swap out well yeah you
can you can do different aesthetic
appearances now in halo 4 and 5 and 3
and reach but yeah they don't have the
certain ones that are actually designed
to really pull you back in although halo
5 the dlc models the free maps that
they'll just keep introducing throughout
the year
um but i that's the thing for halo i
feel like when i play destiny i return
almost out of obligation like i know you
yourself call them chores just as like
certain things like complete bounties
doing arms day
i in halo i return because i want to
because i think it's fun and it's not
something that i feel forced to come
back to because i'm going to miss like
the weekend that zur is selling galahorn
or uh you know like power weapons like
that it's halo i just i think the
gameplay itself is enough to bring me
back and i think that's a little more
what i want out of games something that
doesn't demand that i come back it's
just something that encouraged me um and
yeah i agree with tay i think you know
bungie does a great job of you know
keeping its community involved with
these cool like events that just come
out of nowhere
but i don't know halo i think just the
purity of its gameplay has more
longevity for me
um let's talk about i guess uh
the amount of variety that's in each
game because that's at least when i
think about multiplayer inhaler or i
think about halo generally they're
adding forage obviously in december
there's a lot of different ways to play
that game uh do you think that that's
the same in destiny do you think halo
has sort of a
has more content as it were or do you
think destiny does if you were to like
take everything into account if you were
to take everything into account i think
destiny has more by volume but i think
halo is from each
but just again going back to like each
match itself i think especially with
warzone introduced now it's that pve and
pvp i don't know how much you like
warzone or how much you played it but
you know it's just more like these this
emerging gameplay that happens uh when
you're like you know going for a certain
ai boss or going for a certain capture
point it's just there's a lot of options
to like chase after and then arena you
have a bunch of different game modes and
i think there's a lot of variety and it
changes up how the games unfold a lot
whereas i think i feel like destiny a
lot of times is like these chores that
might give me a slightly better weapon
or
just might be like this exotic bounty
chain that i'm chasing for a week or two
it sounds like for halo the journey is
the reward whereas in destiny maybe the
journey is a means to an end to the
reward is that fair to say
um a little bit uh i i think
again just using the word evolve because
that's what i've been doing um i mean
evolve is better than both of these
games no definitely not let's just not
even go there but like here here's the
kind of cool thing that has happened in
the taking king there there have been
these little
uh missions that come up daily missions
that come up that all of a sudden if if
you unlock some of these secrets
then you actually kind of go down this
path for a special mission that gets you
a special weapon and they've had like
two of those now and those are like
super awesome and i think just part of
it too is i like the weapons in destiny
more they're more unique i think again
it is like a you've i've invested the
time to get them so i feel more affinity
with them right and i i still think the
the like no knock on the sound and the
sound of the gunplay in halo because i
think it's pretty good too but like
there's just something about when i hear
a hawkman get shot or a bully in gemini
like i can tell like what gun i'm
shooting because like it just has a
unique sound and it's awesome um
but yeah i mean like you do i there are
chores things that like but they're
things that
are built in to try to get you to come
back and and like i feel like there's
like so many now that i don't i can't
even come back to do them all which is
like a good or a bad thing depending on
how you look at it but that means
there's always something to do right
like here's something like court of
works it's part of destiny's taken king
expansion that was not in the game where
you and potentially nine stranger or
eight other strangers or
two other people on your fire team could
do if you wanted to to you know get some
loot or just have some fun together um
so they just have so many activities you
can do and
they also have pvp modes that they come
every like month or two for iron banner
or they have like a more serious one in
trials of osiris where it's the more
competitive mode of like here's three on
three almost like wow arena style um you
know the higher you get the better items
you get and yeah you are chasing stuff
but i think that's part of i guess maybe
the addiction
i'll admit that that's fine like that's
part of what you're why are you playing
the game right that's why you're playing
that game though but it's it's one that
keeps growing and uh they keep adding
more things as long as you can pay for
it why would you say it or not
uh yeah i think by and large just halo
and halo 5 especially it always
destiny undoubtedly has more to do i
think i just feel as if halos is more
worth doing again because i don't feel
obligated i don't feel like i'm missing
out if i'm not playing it's just all on
my terms and i'm coming back in my own
leisure and i think it's i i think
inherently it's not designed the same
way as destiny i think bungie did a
great job in encouraging people to stick
around and come back but i think 343 did
a better job with halo 5 to actually
just make me love playing it and just in
terms of
you're right up to now like there has
been a lot of money spent on destiny
again it's like a value proposition for
me i think it's fine for me because i
enjoy it i spend a lot of time so the
the money spent is not that bad but i
will say
they have added micro transactions which
is kind of weird but it doesn't affect
the game so i'm totally fine with it
it's emotes it's stuff like that dances
um you know
and whatnot that you can buy for silver
and i've heard that they're testing
these emotes and these micro
transactions because they might use
these the the funds they make from this
to give free story dlc and stuff like
that going forward and so maybe this
halloween event that they had that's
pretty big um
is like a test case of let's see you
know what the people how much they spend
and like if they spend enough money
maybe you won't pay for dlcs anymore and
the whales can maybe pay for everyone
else
yeah does it seem weird to the company
though sorry i'm being i'm supposed to
be that's fine not you know
have no partisanship in this um but if
you're talking about a team that has a
10-year contract with activision to make
a game who employs plus 200 people do
you really think dlc sales is what's
going to make them make new story
content for the game i mean it's
possible i
again like that's just what i've seen in
stories like that's what they've been
putting out exactly so it's it's it that
could those could just be missions or
events right like but it's a it's a nice
little it's just interesting i think
like half the because both of you enjoy
both games and think there's pluses and
minuses in both but it seems like so
much of it has got to that got to be
down to like the way we play whereas
like you kind of wanted an experience
where you don't feel criticized for not
keeping up with it where you don't feel
like you're being manipulated and you
can go in have some fun and then leave
whereas you're very much into the idea
of having a
like a character that's yours which you
couldn't have in halo because you
couldn't have a character that has the
gun that you earned and like the rep
that you earned and the you know various
currencies and level that you weren't
because if you're playing halo then you
basically be hitting a reset
largely
every single time you're going to play
it do you think it's like it's just like
a different stroke for different folks
kind of situation
probably i i mean like i i thought halo
5 tempe was like pretty good like that
was okay i think some of the story and
and some of the marketing for it wasn't
me you know like it kind of got me there
and i think warzone's kind of fun if you
have enough people but again you can
have like weird experiences with any pvp
fps where you get rolled and you're just
like well that sucked yeah i mean
um but you know in destiny you end up
being able to play single player if
you're not a pvp so you like because
like when you're done with the campaign
and like when you've done the campaign
co-op like what's left other than pvp in
halo right so it's like i think that i
mean if you want to talk about what's
left in games in destiny you reach that
pretty much around the same time it's
just that then they brought out an
expansion pack for it right
no i'm definitely not sitting on the
fence anymore that's fine but like wait
i've not played it
but i mean
you're
again yes you might have to pay for the
next dlc but if you've been playing
you're probably gonna buy it and you're
getting new content right right right
like would you would would somebody
that's playing halo wanna pay for like
they're not gonna be able to play pay
for more story obviously because it's
halo 6 right but i think if you could
tell mike that he could pay ten to
fifteen dollars for potential yeah like
i'm with you like i've spent five
dollars on rocket league [ __ ] but
you can't just sit there and say that
that destiny has more content out to get
than halo does if you complete the
campaign because it's actually got less
it's just that they have a pipeline for
more of it sure sure it's more of a
platform than yes yeah than a second
installment a trilogy like halo 5 as but
at the same time are you still going to
play some more destiny do you think
because you obviously like destiny yeah
like that's what i was telling him we
played games very differently he's more
he can play way more at a time than i
can um but i think
destiny i would be playing more if i
wasn't reviewing so many other games and
just trying to play as many as i could
during the fall but i think uh halo 5 is
the one that i'm going to be kind of
coming back to some lunch break and
everything i'm playing because again i
think i think by and large halo just
respects my time more than destiny does
um and i think value is my time i'm sure
well i'm sure bungie values my time but
oh they value your time yeah my time but
um i just i think halo is
my time better spent when i'm trying to
play a game i really want to play in
between like everything else coming out
cool gentlemen thank you so much for
coming on chewing the fat destiny versus
halo 5 and a great time for uh all fans
of uh online first person shooters as
well there's so many great games out to
play there uh yeah thank you so much for
coming on and let us know what you guys
think in the comments below do you are
you fan of destiny are you fan of halo 5
guardians which one do you think
respects your time more and which one's
just plain old better let us know in the
comments below and how does the show
today the lobby is done second live
stream of the day can we stop doing
these now maybe a little bit yeah pick a
winner pick a winner talking to all of
you pick a winner i gotta pick a winner
my gut would would always i know say i
have yeah i have my issues with destiny
have more to do with
the
psychology behind it rather than the
game but then i'm the [ __ ] i used to
play world of warcraft so okay
there it is i just love a good kearney
game you know what i'm saying
god damn it
that's a shell scale yeah exactly yeah
we just shoot everything outside now um
god i'm just thinking actually this
might be one of the last episodes we do
up here we're moving in like
next three weeks right
i think we'll have like one more i think
we got one solid one maybe two studios
start looking different on the lobby
right it might be pretty big we're all
going downstairs
like that and this might take that wall
is definitely not coming
big rigs will be coming definitely yeah
of course oh man the game boxes i know
all those game boxes have to throw
someone away maybe now we definitely
there's halo wars halo wars is there the
best halo it's right there and they're
making a second one they are making a
second one i was at the gamescom
briefing when they
said halo wars and
no one on the ground ready
i actually i didn't love the first one
but created it was kind of fun the fact
that yeah
it was fun for six hours yeah but the
fact that creative assembly is doing yes
too is pretty cool and 343 will be
involved
they're way into their collaborations
the moment because they're also doing
the uh
the world of warhammer one right
yeah i liked it i got a preview up on
game spot for like a month ago i think
or something check it out all right
we're done what are you doing this week
i'm what am i doing this week what are
you doing this week well
so that you can answer i'm gonna
hopefully get on the overwatch beta
vegas cross all right and then i also
hear that we may be getting an early
copy of another game
which we can't talk about oh [ __ ] a few
of them right i think so i think we
might get a few copies ah i don't want
to halo morris the world yeah
can't wait it's set in the
post apocalypse can't wait halo wars 2.
looking forward to it uh yeah so we'll
have a bunch more content about all that
mess and more this weekend next on
gamespot.com thank you as ever for
watching the show live if you're
watching this on demand how you doing
put on your underpants you sick bastard
and we'll see you guys next week thanks
everyone in the back mary kish joshua
eric tay who
dost out on them and just sat down here
for the whole show instead way to go bro
thanks guys
thank you so much i will see you next
time tuesday 2pm pacific right here on
gamespot adios
you